thank you
after several hours of searching under
extremely difficult conditions rescue
workers brought up the bodies of dozens
of miners using the same gated lift the
workers had used to begin their day 300
meters down
the cause of the explosion on Friday
evening is not known yet and will become
part of the investigation what is clear
for now is the huge loss of life and
damage it has caused
some of the workers who were close to
the surface were able to escape
this is
we saw a horrible scene it cannot be
described it's very sad they're all my
friends friends I eat and drink with at
the weekend they all had dreams they all
had families some were married some were
single
the Turkish president
visited the survivors and paid tribute
to the workers
of course we will determine how the
explosion happened and whether there is
anyone responsible through
administrative and legal investigations
we no longer want to see deficiencies or
unnecessary risks in our minds
the Mind belongs to the state-owned
Turkish hardcore Enterprises
because of Friday's explosion and the
school mine behind me is still under
investigation whatever the outcome 2K
does not have a good safety record
particularly in coal mining despite the
fact the number of accidents has been
decreasing in recent years
eight years ago 301 people were killed
in the nation's worst coal mining
disaster which occurred in the western
town of Soma
this site used to employ 6 000 workers
now the same production is carried out
by 700 workers we will see the same
things if there's no effective
investigation and inspection deterrent
penalties are required Mistakes by a
state company cannot be forgiven the
rescue operation has now ended but many
hear fear unless additional precautions
are taken similar incidents may take
more lives in this coal Rich region CNM
kusolo Al Jazeera amasra Northern turkey